what's going on there reject nation we
made it to the penultimate episode of
all of us are dead
guys if you're here leave a like we very
much appreciate it helps on the algae
read them subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the finale is up then
handsome boys of prepper thanks for
helping us edit down these highlights
and of course you can find the full
length watch along by becoming a parajek
today check out all the content we have
to offer over our patreon let's do it
[Applause]
oh
oh [ __ ] yes
the will
you'll go try something
don't don't leave you're the wrong guy
why would you talk that way to him out
of all people
oh wow
what mercy
[Applause]
wow
why not go with him cause he's gonna
save every damn kid at the school
no
[ __ ] no
oh
[Music]
you need to stop and shoot that guy you
know that yep don't be a hero
all of us are screwed
[Applause]
thank god for the net
freeze
jurassic park
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh i was hoping my predictions were
wrong
aw crap
no you make sure he comes damn it no
no
ah
no
this is like kingdom all over again
oh
it's amazing people sacrifice themselves
just to slow them down yep
by a little time
faster
foreign
oh my god is he a special one in the
last couple episodes i've given up so
much hope for any more of those
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god are they foreshadowing this
come on chucks out you've lived this
long
all right at the end buddy come on i
feel like this is foreign
oh no
oh god give her some blood
oh that eye give her some blood
[Music]
[Music]
oh
let's do this
it's time
go in there
oh
oh boy oh boy wow
she keeps getting knocked down
[Applause]
god it's like a highlight reel of
everyone we've lost oh there's shoes
even she didn't get lucky
lucky hamby oh my god it's the opening
credits
archer him oh yeah come on now
ow
ow
[Music]
damn
it
oh
you saw a [ __ ]
excellent timing
oh
no oh you better kiss her [ __ ] queen
um
[Music]
man
oh
buddy
tyler cause you're going sick
oh
[ __ ] i was hoping this would not happen
yeah
hey
god
[Laughter]
oh dude
[Applause]
but if he does become a hamby he can
just jump off the roof and join them man
she lost both of them today
oh damn
this [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god
what a plan oh my god what a plan
of course
me
[Music]
no
oh
[Music]
play through the pain
this show's being so mean
[Laughter]
they hate us or something
[Applause]
order more drones
no more future for that college yeah
what an ironic name
[Music]
[Music]
wow
wow
wow oh my god
that's so much
oh wow
[Music]
oh wow
oh my god oh my god
this is a really harsh episode
i quite
no more cases
damn how can you sleep maybe he's gonna
go kill himself
i really wonder
i could absolutely see that happening
[Music]
there's wife there's daughter
there it is
here
[Music]
it's good old korean dramas man bushels
of fun
oh
take it away john
keep it positive yes i am just drained
from the amount of fun we had in this
episode the amount of joy and triumph
over insurmountable odds
yeah this was definitely a feel-good
installment no uh this was you know it's
funny when this episode started i had
gotten to the point where i'd come in
like a ironic way back around on guinom
because i was like ah this guy's funny
now i like this guy he's just got one
track mind he's not gonna ever stop
and
you got the wrong emotions with him
while i know but at the same time it's
like he's he's just always looking for
chong son he's always gonna fall off
something big and come back and find
chong's son again and uh
yeah this episode brought it back i felt
like around the time that he reappeared
and really reconnected to you know
actually getting
you know a chance at chung sun
everything else started to kind of
sink further and further as well and
yeah like this was a super
uh emotionally heavy episode
and uh yeah it's like it's not the
between them it's not necessarily the
like yeah you know like you want to see
you know i'm ripped apart or exploded or
something or other he's still alive i i
wonder if the both of them in some way
might still be alive just because again
the the one
one of the couple elements i think you
can rely on is the uh cliffhanger to
opening scene reversal
uh not necessarily that that's gonna be
an all good thing but i don't know i
think
if there's one possible thing they might
still have to to give us a little bit of
a reward i think maybe chong son could
become a hobby although i i don't know i
i have lost
faith on
it's funny ever ever since uh namra
you're like oh this could be it though
maybe everybody who gets bit has a chat
but nah it just hasn't happened so i'm
not really expecting it but i feel like
there's still a a slight possibility it
could happen
i think we're gonna get some type of
flash forward in the next episode
oh this one was really bleak
this is the bleakest one yep the darkest
timeline
for sure for sure uh we watched this is
the all of us are dead episode it is
this is literally a montage cutting
around everyone we've lost
while the people that we're following
are about to be incinerated
the only pride i have
is i called it
you called it i called the firefighter
dad that's right
give me my 200
yeah you really called it they were not
reunited for five minutes
eaten alive
and i called chong son you did
you did i'm the predictor you are the
predict
you are the king of the right who would
have been disappointed if they didn't
you know i think it would be better if
they did my thing
all of us are greg
yes man
yeah
um
no i just kept the i'm really i'm not
i'm not quite processing anything on an
intellectual level right now it's more
just uh
this void
yeah i'm a vessel for darkness at this
moment yes
you're sucking in the light
yeah no i feel you it's it's it's the
yeah it's the most anguished it's the
like there are no rewards practically at
all in this episode and no they give you
no catharsis no catharsis i was like all
right maybe [ __ ] chong's son's gonna
like grab one of them rebars and like
you know smash it into his skull yeah
cut his head off or cave it in or go
through the brain he gets bit he gets
[ __ ] and then he gets his eye gouged
out
and then
he they go down in flames like i i
thought that chong's son uh would have
some type of little moment
because
you know my mom was gone it's taken him
a while to turn
but i don't care let him have his moment
like that's where my mind was at yeah
i'm like they're not giving him his
moment
if he
part of me was going oh they could've
just done his original plan i mean the
plan they could have just done what he
just did there yeah but they didn't he
didn't know about the
vacant pit that was a moment of good
good use of surroundings yeah
so like if they were aware of that he
could have done that originally yeah
where he just like lured everyone up
there and then they all just fell but
nope nope no such luck getting into the
whole school you guys just stood there
the whole time yeah
but eventually you just walk
that's
on
top
is once every last zombie is in they've
already they've reached the height that
he's had them yeah he goes walking yeah
but i mean
that was probably the closest the
episode got i think to giving a
catharsis is when he gets to at least uh
at least say his piece and and you know
he's like i'm not afraid of you
you're still here just because you're
afraid of of you know the the the phone
that's been long since destroyed with
the evidence of you killing the
principal you know like him getting to
at least uh tell him off one more time
was
rewarding in and of itself
i mean they've reached this point in the
show that i've often pondered if we did
live in a zombie apocalypse like would
there be a purpose in living
would i just want to turn
yeah it's that age-old question of
what's the age-old question that our
great-great-grandparents have been
asking if zombies took over
but you know i mean like yeah the the
the innate human instinct is to keep on
surviving
but
in a situation like this yeah the
intellectual
uh weight to bear of that is like way
advanced and
yeah i don't know well dude namra and
stud muffin
that guy doesn't know what he's getting
himself into he does not
she's not gonna be able to control this
forever you're not gonna be able to
guarantee that you can be fine if she
bites you and i mean if you do let her
bite you there's no guaranteeing she'll
just like stop at the one
and not like actually eat you
she's a good character man she fought
against her urges yeah
and the urge is almost one it's like
that guy loves her
it's almost as if he's in love with her
i mean
part of me is like dude you don't really
know her as well as you you think you
should the matter part is
there's no one really around you know
in this hopeless existence now what if
you guys are incompatible i'm just
saying what if you find out that you
don't have anything in common you know
she's always that her music on what if
you guys don't connect over music or
anything you know clearly you were once
a bully that's a way different
upbringing than her affluence you know
which for an extreme
best guy do you think this show has lost
any sight of i mean was he a bully was
he just a fighter do you think this show
has lost any sight of its original
themes i feel like they haven't really
carried that
have they am i am i missing it they see
i felt like they were trying to bring it
back around
when
chong son was telling guinom
you know repeating that speech again
of
like you might think you're all powerful
but you're really no different than you
were before yeah you're just trying to
cover your ass and he started crying
greena yeah
like you really got cut to the core
of guinom's real emotions yeah
yeah i don't know i mean i i
part of me feels like
because this has been the development of
a situation i mean the themes
carry
and i mean it comes back world's a bully
kind
well yeah i mean i feel like there's
there's more to a lot of people yeah
there's the bullying theme and then the
theme of
the appearances based bureaucracy
that leads to the mishandling of these
types of events and situations sure sure
and uh
yeah like i felt like this is
it's a bit more in that
side of the court to me at this point in
the show because you know like the
the uh you know the the leader of the
the martial law commander you know he
has that exchange with the councilwoman
and
you know things like that kind of
brought me back there but it does feel
as though the themes have kind of spread
out from that initial state
and i mean two
i feel like in the emotional beats you
get out of this there is like a mournful
sort of regret adult quality and i think
that there is a certain amount of just
like interesting humanity they use like
i feel like sometimes they're they're
making like an overarching sort of
subtextual
perhaps political comment and then other
times i feel like they're looking in on
the the gray areas of just being the
human being who has to carry these
things out or who
makes any number of these decisions and
what condition are you under and because
like i think the i think this show is
weirdly just a study of life yeah yeah
because it feels like it's just
examining what might happen on all these
different scales and and in all these
different positions across this one
unifying scenario
or anjo
yeah poron joe
she lost a lot this episode yeah
everyone around her is being a hero
today
sacrificing themselves
they have some really really heartfelt
moments though
like
for for as much as it's like you know
heart-wrenching to be like ugh they're
only you know actualizing their
affections because of the situation
at hand but still those were lovely
touching
moments
and i mean to go back to the guy just
real quick the the martial luck
commander like i thought they did a nice
job because
at certain times with that character
you've been like whoa
it's a little extreme and then a lot of
other times you're like well i don't
know from your perspective it seems like
you're doing the best you can with a
[ __ ] scenario
so this theme seemed the theme of
today's episode seemed to be about
regret
mm-hmm
yeah
wish i told you then which side your
hair looked best on
well even like with the
creator of the virus yeah
yeah and then marshall
law commander
oh well pretty good [ __ ] happens right
that's right sometimes your experiment
gets out of control
well even two i mean i i i liked by this
point too with the creator i i
there were points at which i was like
okay that's a nifty exposition
device but i thought it was nice the way
they've interspersed that throughout the
season where you're kind of yeah you do
learn about that guy's journey
in the past as the present unfolds you
know you learn about the first trial
across the expanding of like the the
the real thing
you know
a lot of real grace about it
yeah it's fun stuff man fun stuff dude
yeah some hilarious jokes in this
episode some really good physical gags
another archer guy got the hit oh well
we got one more to go
see you guys soon thanks for being here
[Music]